hey 42 here sometimes after you spend
two hours trying to pick a film on
Netflix you begin to wonder how the
world functions when we all have to make
so many decisions elections referendums
swipe left or right sleep in or be on
time raspberry ripple or mint choc chip
you are constantly forced to make
choices about every aspect of your life
from the big to the small but it's hard
isn't it you have to find a balance
between what you want and what you think
is good for you and the people around
you and there's so much compromise
because you can't research every choice
so you just have to go on the limited
information that you have available so
if you want to know why you broke up
with the love of your life why you pay -
what Zoolander - and why you got that
brownie tattoo it's because you're bad
at making decisions we all are and this
is why history it's supposedly something
we study so we can learn from the
mistakes of the past the thing is we
don't really do it we have a very strong
tendency to look at how things have been
very recently and ignore things that
happened a long time ago if you got food
poisoning last week from some service
station sushi you'd probably be very
cautious about eating any seafood right
now
but if that was a year ago you'll
happily stop your fate of raw fish like
a ravenous seal this is called the
recency effect financial investors are a
great example of this it was greed and
willful blindness that led the world
economy to collapse in 2007 causing the
Great Recession
so after such a major disaster we surely
have many more checks and balances in
place so that this can't happen again
yeah about that we don't nothing really
changed the market recovered and it's
pretty much business as usual now
because the stock market as a whole
focuses on a much shorter window
typically you 1 to 2 years 2007 is
almost 10 years ago
who cares stocks are up now and your
broker just bought a toilet made of gold
invest your brain is absolutely
brilliant
cutting patterns that's a lot of it job
well lat and remembering lines of
annoying songs mean things your ex said
and places where you haven't left your
wallett think about facial recognition
you know your friends and families faces
no matter what angle you see them from
you're not matching an exact image for
memory your brain just sees a pattern of
how their features relate to one another
and makes the deduction that it's your
grandma and not your girlfriend thank
God for that so we often see patterns
where there are not like spotting shapes
in the clouds it's called the clustering
illusion we don't have a good natural
appreciation of the randomness of the
universe and we often feel that events
have to even out on a much shorter
timescale than they actually do
take a coin toss for example on most
coins it's roughly 50/50 whether you get
heads or tails and over a long enough
time scale the results of the flips will
echo that but the previous results have
absolutely no bearing on the outcome of
the next flip
if you flip something like tails tails
heads tails heads heads tails heads
tails heads then everyone's happy but if
you flipped 10 tails in a row then there
are going to be some eyebrows raised and
some people might think you're actually
magic or just cheating but both these
results actually have an equal
probability but if I ask you to bet on
the next flip after a run of five
consecutive tails you're far more likely
to say heads then after just one or two
flips of tails this is called the
gamblers fallacy and is the main reason
why you shouldn't take your credit card
to the casino another major part of
decision-making is salience this just
means how noticeable or memorable
something is and the most common area
where this is a factor is safety if you
ask many Americans to lift the biggest
dangers facing their country they are
very likely to list terrorism around
3,500 US citizens have been killed by
terrorism in the last 20 years and
although this is a lot of people it's
tiny in comparison to things like car
accidents and
answer and about the same amount of
people who drowned in swimming pools but
major events such as 9/11 understandably
take up a much more important and
memorable place in people's forth
processes nobody sits down with a cup of
coffee read an article about lung cancer
and immediately panics and starts
shooting smokers what happens is that
extremes both good and bad have a much
bigger influence on us than they should
do say you've been drinking tequila most
weekend for a few years and the worst
that has ever happened was a headache
and the occasional awkward text but one
Saturday you go a little bit overboard
and end up dressed as Pikachu asking
random girl to capture you in their
pokeballs and suddenly it's a deist
tequila for the rest of your life all
the good times are forgotten and that
one massive cringe moment stays forever
this is called salience and it can
majorly skew your decision-making since
we all find decision-making difficult
for wider issues we often take the
easiest option just going along with
what everyone else does this is called
the bandwagon effect it happens all the
time and nothing causes people to reject
their own opinion for the sake of
joining the herd the fashion industry
demonstrates this constantly your
favorite outfit of 10 years ago probably
looks like something you'd wear to a
costume party now and it's not because
you suddenly looked in the mirror and
realized that freak water lumps short
and a scarf made you look like a
confused sailor you just saw that no one
else was wearing them anymore so you
took it off but you really should have
burnt it politics is heavily affected by
the bandwagon effect and it's why the
idea of momentum is so important we the
voters want to feel like we are on the
winning side
so feeling that the candidate is going
to win makes people more likely to vote
for them and creates a kind of feedback
loop you see this in presidential
primaries in the US and the obsession
over states like Iowa are New Hampshire
since they are the first to vote but I
don't want you to think we are complete
sheep and immediately just follow what
the majority says we also have a donkey
like stubbornness when it
changing our minds the bandwagon effect
is strong when someone is undecided but
once that choice has been made a large
opposition opinion is actually more
likely to make them double down on their
choice rather than reverse their
position confirmation bias is our
tendency to interpret everything in a
way that fits with what we already
believe rather than using new
information to change our position if
you need an example just look at every
argument on the Internet
rather than listening to other people's
ideas we just spend hours on Wikipedia
trying to find something to undermine
them and then hoping that they use the
wrong version of your so we can throw it
in there a literate face and call our
mother a Nazi slot or something like
that there is a book called Diceman by
Luc Reinhart about a psychologist who
tested you can give up your morals by
passing your decision-making over to the
role of a dice so you can say hey it
wasn't my choice to steal this bagel the
dice told me to do it and if you get
away with stealing the bagel then you
might begin to think that you have hit
on some brilliant decision-making
process this is called outcome bias if
you had a multiple-choice test and you
decided to choose by always picking the
longest answer and then you got an a on
that test you'd be inclined to think
that this was a great way to do all
tests this positive outcome would
justify your stupid tactic and you might
decide to do it again because hey it
worked last time it's similar to the
idea of lucky objects just because that
underwear got you through one exam
please don't wear them all the way
through finals you'll get some sort of
infection our come by is often confused
with hindsight and although they have a
lot in common hindsight is about memory
in that you changed a story of what
happens after you see the result making
it seem like you knew what was going to
happen all along no you're not the
Messiah you're a very naughty boy unfine
aliy we come to anchoring which is
probably something truly awful on
urbandictionary.com
basically you are a little limpet and
you'd like to cling to the first rock
that you come across the first
information that you guess on any
subject is often likely to carry
much more weight than it should it's a
useful tool in negotiations since the
first amount someone says is then the
starting point and then both sides dance
around that number so if you want to
haggle for a low price make sure you are
the first one to throw out a number
anchoring also has a big impact in tests
and surveys since if you begin the
question with something negative you are
more likely to get a negative answer
once surprisingly politicians use this
to huge effect all the time using a
seemingly innocent poll to actually
influence the way people are voting so
now you are left with a conundrum which
is more important
recency or anchoring we talked most
recently about anchoring but we anchored
on recency are you doubting your
decision-making yet thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42 this tower of
testosterone is Danish mountain beast
Peter Freudian he is the most
interesting man in the world each part
of the tree wants to kill you in a
different organizing way the fruits it
grows look like apples smell like apples
and even taste like apples put her nuts
apples